Wow over a thousand subscribers and it
just thanks to you guys
ladies gents good people of YouTube I
have finally passed the 1000 subscriber
mark and I'm not gonna lie it feels
great to know that my particular brand
of entertainment is appreciated by you
guys but this video is not to talk about
me much I am making this video to thank
you all honestly speaking thank you so
much for subscribing to me thank you for
the subscriptions support and all the
kind words now I've met a lot of great
people on YouTube there are a lot of
people I could thank but there are two
people in particular that I need to
think right now
because I genuinely believe that without
these two people I at least wouldn't be
as far as I am this fast I don't know if
my average is fast I'm just saying they
took note of me and helped me out when I
was under my movie man one night in one
channel the first thing he goes out to a
youtuber named decadence 7 no no she's
gonna be like you didn't have to do that
but I know I've but I'm going to so deal
with it I mean I had like five videos up
in 30 subscribers or so and decadence 7
saw me and said hey I like him I shall
make a video speaking kindly of his
whimsical ways though I'm sure it went
something like that in any case she made
a video about me and I got more
subscribers because of it so Thank You
decadence Evan now the other youtuber
that took note of me and gave me a
shout-out by doing an entire video about
me his fellow youtuber and great guy
theory of the film fan now I personally
think theory the film fans a lawyer
because whether he believes a movie is
good or bad he will lock his case down
so airtight it does not matter what you
think you think about a movie watch a
review by fury the film fan and you will
see his point of view by the end and
that I think is talented but since I
personally think he's too likable to be
a lawyer I'm gonna go ahead and assume
he's just gifted in the Jedi mind trick
but again theory the film fans saw my
stuff exploded entertained him I guess
because I said transformers 2 was like
the caca Lexington steel and I still
profess that but I do owe fear you the
film fan you help me out big time and
you sir also rock now I know both
decadent 7 inferior the film fan are
both going to message me like as you
watch this they're gonna tell me I
didn't need to do this and they were
happy to do it
and I know but I'm appreciative and I
personally think nice people should be
thanked in life I just that's how I am
that's how I think it should be so thank
you but they are not the only ones that
need to be thanked all of you you
personally watching this I thank you
it's kind of funny whenever I message
people back people are always so amazed
that I message them it's almost like
youtubers out there never
message people back I personally believe
that people in entertainers need to
remember how they are where they are
like I personally need to remember that
I have the subscribers I have because of
you guys because without you guys I
would be talking to dead cyberspace and
that would be a weird feeling for me so
thank you all thank you to the people
who recently subscribed to me thank you
to the people who have been subscribed
to me since I was on my movie man one
night in one channel again thank you to
all you who are watching this you all
rocked you keep me going a few months
ago I was just a guy with a camera who
just wanted to rant about a movie now
I'm a guy with a camera who likes to
rant about movies and stuff not sure
where I was going with that but the
point is I have officially found my drug
of choice and it's making these videos
and entertaining you guys so now that
I've hit a thousand subscribers I'm a
person of goals so let's try to get
10,000 subscribers I honestly intend on
shooting for two million subscribers why
not - honestly a fred can get a million
and a half i will at least shoot for two
million subscribers so on that i hope
you all have or had a great Christmas or
Hanukkah or boxing day or whatever it is
you celebrate and you can check out
decadence Evan and fury of the film fans
channel located in the sidebar I suggest
you go check them out and there are more
videos to come so stay tuned as we go on
to 10,000 and always remember you guys
Rock